hey guys and welcome back to grizzly
Valley today I'll lay the groundwork on
the Japanese area which much like the
Alpine area is going to have a coaster
as a centerpiece and in this case I
chose for a aerodynamics corkscrew
coaster a couple of reasons really it's
the only other coaster type I also
really felt it would fit the Japanese
area most as a type of tongue-in-cheek
really because Japanese parks are really
known for their terrible aerodynamics
coaster knock-offs and what they like to
call jet coasters which is coasters with
this type of track which aren't exactly
smooth to say the least so that's also
why I wanted to go for a rather standard
layouts just a double looping double
corkscrew layout and try to at least
make it not entirely smooth so there
were some part where I intentionally
left it and not really that great but I
do have to say at this point in the
time-lapse I was still deciding to leave
out the COI screws because if there's
anything that I would want to critique
this game on its the fact that the
elements in the game so far that it
gives you are really terrible but that
said it's still a part of an alpha game
and they also didn't want to originally
put the coaster construction into this
version of the Alpha yet so I shouldn't
talk about that but yeah the corkscrews
I thought weren't really good enough to
actually feature that's why I first
built this helix but you actually see
later on in this video I decided to
build my own corkscrews which is part of
the reason why this video in the end
actually took three days to actually
make which is also why it's a little bit
on the late side compared to my upload
rate lately but yeah that's all for the
coaster for now the most important part
that I'll be doing in this episode is
work on the station which more or less
will also be a prototype for the rest of
the Japanese theme and there is quite a
lot to actually talk about this and I
didn't explicitly mention this yet
really so far I want to go for a
Japanese theme and this is a couple of
reasons I obviously still want to
experiment and see what you can actually
do with the pieces in-game but this
feels a lot more experimental than just
trying the Alpine theme or trying the
main streets
because both the Alpine theme in the
main street are at least still European
and I think much more closely resemble
what the pieces in the Pirates and
generic theme actually like whereas a
Japanese theme isn't even a Western it's
a completely different style of building
and it relies on a couple of things
which simply aren't there in the game
yet I've seen a couple of people try the
theme so far free the bear actually has
a series a let's play series on YouTube
in which he's already tackled a more
general Asian style which is really cool
to check out as well and some other
people have tried the theme as well but
there are a couple of really essential
things missing or many essential things
missing really and the thing that is
there is just that one inclined curved
roof which is sort of the base of all of
the Asian building and I decided to
within the Asian theme go for
specifically a Japanese theme because
the differences between the very similar
Chinese and Korean theme are quite
important
Japanese theme uses more wood less
paints and less weight less different
colors and things like that are very
uncommon in Japanese buildings whereas
you do quite often see it in Korean or
Chinese buildings there's also an issue
with that
Korean buildings and this is an issue in
the game in general because Asian
buildings do you have these little
pointy bits at the end of the roofs
where they curve up and where Japanese
building buildings only have this pointy
bit curved up a little bit at the very
end of the roof for Korean buildings the
entire roof is a curve so there was no
way I could actually do Korean and
comparing Chinese and Japanese I just I
have very limited knowledge of Japanese
buildings so really not too sure how
well this is going to work out in the
end but my Chinese is pretty much
non-existent and it really uses a lot
different materials which I really
figured in the end isn't going to be
quite as possible since the Japanese
theme uses a lot more raw wood and that
wood texture which I think the one that
is in-game and we have a couple of
pieces of is quite useful to maybe turn
into Japanese buildings
so about the station building
specifically I wanted to start off with
the roof here which does complicate
things if I want to get into interiors
and things like that though that said I
think I might want to do interiors and
smaller details on live streams because
it doesn't quite work as well on time
lapses which is sped up twelve times but
another important an important reason
why I wanted to start with the roof is
because the roof is really in Japanese
culture often the most prominent and
important feature of a building and you
can almost really tell what's building
any building in Japan is just by looking
at the roof it's definitely sometimes
even in terms of heights the roof itself
is higher than the rest of the building
has many details and decorations and
Japanese buildings have multi-layered
roofs as well so that's why I wanted to
start with it just to get the general
shape of it done which is really the
sort of main part in the middle with two
wings on the side it isn't particularly
inspired by any specific building I just
sort of looked up many Japanese Buddhist
temples which is the general style which
I figured would at least be most closely
possible in the game even though there
are not actually pieces for it so it's
definitely lacking on the details and
the roof shape is also really hard to
get close to but that was a style which
I generally wanted to follow the only
thing which looking back I'm still not
sure about when it comes to the station
and might well remove is the roof
sticking out in the front and at the
back there is that roof sticking out
very similar to the roof that sticks out
in the Alpine station but it's a very
uncommon feature of Japanese building so
I might want to release a remove that
and just keep the empty roof but this
was really just a decision which I made
from the game perspective and also a
theme-park perspective that just the
flat roof doesn't quite look too
interesting and I don't have the
interesting details on the roof which
real Japanese roofs have to make it less
boring so really figured this extra roof
sticking out at the front and the back
could maybe bring it out a little bit
more and make it less of a boring
building to look at which from a
theme-park perspective now this is
something I might want to note as well
might be helpful as well because
there isn't a lot of reference when it
comes to Asian styles in theme parks
it's actually extremely uncommon I found
there was actually a bush gardens with
an Asian theme in Houston which I wanted
to find some things about for reference
but it there's nothing about it since
it's already gone for over 30 years and
the only real good reference is abcott
which has a very small Japanese pavilion
but even then it's like you might also
want to you might want to call it theme
park Japanese almost it's Japanese it
uses the Japanese details and overall
shapes of it but it doesn't follow the
exact rules of Japanese buildings and
that's basically what I would like to
say I'm sort of following in this case
as well especially given how Japanese
buildings much like the Roman or Greek
buildings are very specific with their
dimensions and there are different
ideologies and philosophies between the
exact dimensions and makeup of these
buildings which is something which I
won't be able to add and I'll really
just try to make that theme-park
Japanese where it really looks Japanese
and try to decorate it as much as I can
and just see what I can really do there
but it won't be like a realistic
Japanese themed temple in the end that's
basically when it boils down to though
that said it's definitely inspired by
the Japanese Buddhist temples and I'll
still sort of follow that same logic in
here with a small step or a small
staircase leading up to the station with
a path in front of it and decorating
that with some classical Japanese
elements which is which are probably
marked the most recognizable elements of
Japanese architecture for Westerners or
at least so I figured though that said
just a quick moment I would like to take
is that I'm always up for feedback about
Japanese buildings especially about
people who are more knowledgeable than I
am
I actually got most of my knowledge
about it actually from a very long time
ago but I can't exactly boast about it
there was a roller coaster tycoon 3
competition lost somewhere where I
participated in a team and we made a
Japanese theme park which I did some
research for but we eventually lost the
competition so that
doesn't entirely help a whole deal but I
also had an incredible Wikipedia spree
last couple of days which was also
really interesting but aside from that I
am obviously still a westerner and I'm
probably quite prone to something which
i think is very common pitfall and
making Japanese buildings in theme park
games is something which I very often
see happening is that you make Japanese
buildings or any type of Asian building
by using the elements and incorporating
them into your building but the overall
building still has the makeup or entire
composition of a Western building which
is really hard to explain but it's
basically Asian buildings are completely
differently laid out and have different
conversation than European buildings
since the very core philosophies and
ideas on what they're built is entirely
different like Japanese buildings don't
have these fixed rooms with fixed
purposes but they have sliding rooms and
like any room can be used for anything
and things like that and they eventually
end up making the entire architectural
style completely different and one of
the things which I'm probably going to
end up doing somewhat is make these
buildings with definitely Japanese
elements but still an an overall sort of
Western atmosphere anyway I'm going
crazy Lee off-topic again ok so I do
actually talk a bit about my process of
doing this
the most important part were definitely
the inclined roofs I think and without
that this thing would have would not
have even been possible but they hardly
really the biggest challenge in trying
to make this happen was the lack of
corner roofs where the corners of roofs
are very common and very prominent in
Japanese buildings but there are no
actual corner buildings corner roofs in
any of the tile sets except for the
Spanish one which obviously isn't going
to work for Japanese at all because of
the texture so I am stuck with only
gable roofs which makes it very hard to
make kept eni's buildings since they
very often have these corner roofs so
that was one really major limitation
which you sort of had to get over in the
design of this building
and that's also why I chose to build it
in the way that I eventually ended up
doing it and the basic way of making
this building was actually quite simple
in terms of the grid it didn't involve
different grids at all since it's pretty
much a straight stucco walls which are
very much on the grid and it's mostly
very time-consuming details that I
wanted to get in Japanese buildings have
a lot of very intricate details in the
woodwork and obviously I don't have
these very beautifully sculpted out
details on the woodwork but I still
wanted to sort of make it look similar
and visually similar from a distance at
least by adding all of these little
beams horizontal vertical and roof beams
to at least so it emulates the wooden
details that Japanese buildings have
which is why this eventually turned out
to be quite time-consuming building and
took I think yeah it was nearly two
hours to build these station in total
but that was that I also wanted to add a
quick transfer track over here with a
small storage building where I was
doubting for quite a while if I wanted
to make this a themed storage building
or if I just wanted to make it a grey
box because basically you need a storage
building more or less to store the
causing that you don't use unless your
station is large enough to put them in
there but I needed to get a separate
building in here and it was really
wondering if I wanted to make it a
generic building or not and in the end I
went for this weird combination of
making this side themed to at least not
break the immersion of the Asian theme
as you approach this building from the
roller-coaster itself but for the other
side I just sort of made that a generic
back stage parts where there's just air
conditioner sticking out and HVAC or at
least that's the idea so it's sort of
themed on one side so it doesn't make
the immersion but aside from that it's
really just a simple little storage
building I just really wanted to add
that for realism it's obviously not
functional and at the moment it's damn
near impossible to actually make a
convincing transfer track so not
entirely sure how well it's going to
really work out in the end but I want
to just have this for a bit of realism
in anyway and there was some space left
here so decided to give that a try since
I still did have to try making a
transfer track and this would be a good
opportunity to at least see if there's a
future nuts I would actually be really
cool to see transfer tracks in the game
in the future though that's just some
random wish I suppose but yeah that's
the station and the similarly Buddhist
architecture building next to it which
I'm not sure what to make out of but the
station is very much a temple inspired
building and I think I'll also sort of
theme the area around the station to be
sort of this temple or Palace ish area
and make the rest of the Japanese area
more like a smaller japanese town so
less with the quite large architecture
the station is quite large which is it's
not much larger than the Alpine station
but it's one of my worries about the
station is that it may be a bit too big
for its environment but yeah that's more
or less the fancy parts of the Japanese
area you could almost say and the rest
of the area is going to have some more
flat rights and smaller townhouses and
restaurants or at least that's the
general idea
I don't actually have an actual layouts
for it yet or any specific plans but
that'll just sort of come up in the
future and I'm not really too worried
about that and actually really looking
back at this my station was my biggest
real worry about this part of the park
since it was really the only section
where I didn't have lot of confidence in
since I already practiced quite a bit
with the Japanese theme and try to throw
out a couple of buildings and smaller
details just to see how it would
actually work out and while it's right
some smaller houses I didn't actually
try a building as large as this station
yet so that's why I was really not too
sure about it and then here at the
bottom I wanted to do this thing which
you commonly see around temples as well
they are placed on this small stone base
which is slightly raised off the ground
and they have these steps in front of
them but well that's a pretty realistic
thing I do have to say this base is way
higher than it is for any realistic
Japanese camp
which is purely because it's obviously
the station of the roller coaster and
the track is pretty high so I didn't
want to race that a bit but at least I
wanted to give it that same stone
foundation that Japanese temples often
have and for a cue I actually this is
also one of the reasons why it took such
a very long time to record this episode
I started with a queue in the middle of
nowhere pretty much and figured I would
get a queue building but instead of that
like sort of halfway through making that
building I really figured it didn't look
too great so instead I might as well try
something which is very similar to how
the Imperial Palace in Kyoto has these
walls around it many palaces and castles
and Japan have this as well and I really
figured that would actually be pretty
nice because these walls have these
fancy gates and I was really thinking
having one of these gates as an entry
sort of to the queue would actually be
quite impressive and nice and would also
allow the queue entrance to be pretty
close to the station building itself so
I really figured well might as well go
for this and see how that ends up and I
was really much happier with that than
having a station building so that's some
lost footage over there and also
something which I forgot to talk about
which happened a couple of minutes ago I
had those couple of shots about the
corkscrews in and you see the corkscrews
over here in a lot of paths work now
which is something that I cut out at
least for the most part because it was
painful to make those cork screws in the
end it almost took me two hours but I
really wanted to make these custom cork
screws just to be able to make them
larger and more smooth than the in-game
ones and I am really happy with how they
came out and how they sort of make their
way over the parts but it was just hours
of trial and error which don't work out
well for making a time-lapse video
whatsoever so that was also cut out of
this video which is why this is more of
like a collect collection of different
time lapses than anything but while
you're missing out on that I do have to
say I'm incredibly happy with how the
cork screws came out in the end they're
more smooth than I even expected and as
as much as I was really doubting the
in-game elements you can actually make
inversions yourself and
biggest trick to this is really placing
some things first and then just have
some oddly shaped track and then just go
back to it and tweak it a bit and smooth
it out a bit and work with on the
banking long enough and sort of finalize
it until at some point you really
figured well this is going to be good
enough and just by sort of doing that
for quite some time you can actually
make some really cool smooth elements
which is really nice to see anyway this
is the sort of the palace wall which I
figured I wanted to have here I
obviously won't decorated it too much
because while there is no real sense in
adding Windows to a wall here so I just
want to do quickly at this wall around
the Q which I will return to at some
point in a distant future but not quite
yet where I just want to very simply
theme the Q which is very similar to I
think I'll do it very similar to how
Matterhorn bobsleds has their Q which
actually also goes underneath this roof
for a bit and also has this part where
it snakes through a garden and I really
think that would be very nice to try in
here and make a little garden in between
these walls and let the Q go through
that it's nothing too spectacular but I
really just wanted to do something with
this which was not completely putting a
building over the Q because that just
seemed very much out of place so here's
how I quickly made the transfer track
really it's something which I did try
once before I yeah I did actually yeah
what am I saying actually that had an
episode 5 I think yeah so I did try it
trying to drag before but not actually
completely finalized it so that happened
this time and I also wanted to add these
quick little lanterns over here because
they're in essential part of the temples
in Japan they also they all have these
little stone lanterns you might know
what I'm talking about and I think they
call them Toro which are I think are
really beautiful and I really wanted to
get along the sides here sort of along
the entranceway to the temple as you
would very often see and they don't
actually work I tried putting some
lanterns inside them but the lighting
does some strange stuff when it's inside
a chimney though that sir chimneys are
absolutely everything actually lanterns
right now as well
but yeah it means I can't exactly put
the lanterns inside the chimney which
was kind of a bummer since the lighting
just doesn't work that well so decided
in the end to put some lighting on top
of them but still the over idea is that
oh and also these plants I was so happy
with how these turned out I made a
couple of this before this a couple of
these before this video is well it's
basically a couple of wooden posts and
then just some bushes on top of it to
make some of those Japanese plants
because one of the big things at the
moment of course is the lack of
vegetation so I was really afraid that
if I would just use the legacy stuff in
there then
well it's any Park is going to end up
looking very similar to other parks
since everybody uses the same vegetation
and this is especially true for Japanese
gardens because they are very different
from European gardens and it especially
comes down to the way like they have
these trim bushes and trimmed topiary
like plants but unlike the European
topiary is where they shape them into
elephants and cones and whatnots they
have this more like flowy idea of little
so hard to describe little blobs of of
trim bushes that sort of flow in an area
and sort of like wave-like patterns and
that's something which is sort of wanted
to try my hand at quickly with those
bushes then I was actually quite happy
with how it turned out the posts don't
even look too fake and then over here I
just as a quick little entrance I wanted
to make a small wooden torii gates which
you always see at the entrance of any
temple and although I'm of course not
too happy about how it looked in the end
since they obviously aren't really
peaceful for this I'm still surprised
with how it came out so this is how the
finalized or almost finalized station
looks like I should say it's not
entirely final I might still want to add
some small benches and little details
around here and of course the guests are
missing and that just makes it look so
lifeless but yeah this is pretty much
the finished station with the little war
with the entrance in it and some of the
gardens that surround it and looking
back I do have to say this was really
one
of those buildings where during the
building process I was so worried about
how it was going to turn out but
especially with these Gardens added to
it I think it's actually convincingly
Japanese and I'm looking forward to do
the rest of this area actually even
though it's going to be quite different
and it is already very different from
what I've tried so far I think this will
be a lot of fun so we thank you guys for
watching this video and see you guys in
the next one in which I'll be trying to
add some of those smaller houses and
decorate the area a little bit